il semblerait qu'il n'y a pas de blessés
parmi les civils en résultat de ces
frappes à longue distance loin des
frontières et des lignes de front sur
Kiev des drones qui ont été abattus
quelques voitures de particuliers mais
pas de dégâts significations sur les
immeubles sur les maisons au dessin un
bâtiment qui était un école ou une
université ou un collège a été il y a
une incendie mais les Ukrainiens disent
que il n'y a pas de blessés c'était
pendant la nuit les Ukrainiens disent
avoir abattu non seulement ses 18 sur 24
drones mais aussi un certain nombre de
missiles balistiques qu'il ne précise
pas exactement combien mais c'est
effectivement la quatrième nuit de suite
je pense où il y a des attaques à longue
distance que la Russie utilise des
drones et des requêtes aussi
il y a eu aussi mais c'est le cas
presque toutes les nuits en fait des
attaques distances à travers la
frontière et là effectivement il y a eu
des blessés parmi les civils et
notamment dans la région de tchernikif
dans le nord du pays tout près de la
frontière avec la Russie un homme en
civil a été tué aux alentours de 23h
hier soir par un tir d'artillerie